-I feel like you've cracked
the talk-show code
because yours seems like
the most fun one to do.
This is --
-I'm coming for your job,
actually.
-You're coming for my job,
but I'm coming for yours
because you --
-I know that.
I see you
at every fashion event.
I feel like you've been
coming for my job for years.
-I know.
I -- You know what?
I can't seem to get
the runway jobs you have.
I don't know what it is.
[ Light laughter ]
-I'll lend you these shoes,
and I'll teach you the walk.
-Thank you. I'll will -- I'll
start working on my calves now.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-So, your show is --
you watch movies
live in front of an audience
with close friends.
-Yes.
-It seems like a jackpot.
-It's like,
what's not to love about that?
-In front of a live audience.
And it really is -- I feel like
I'm training for your job.
I've got an earpiece in my ear.
I've got cameras from
every angle and a live audience.
And it's a fun experiment.
And it's --
you're watching movies with
my -- with wonderful people.
-How -- Now,
you chose your favorite movies.
What are some of the movies
you've chosen?
-So, "Finding Nemo,"
"Dirty Dancing."
-Great.
-Like, classics.
-Yes.
-And amazing...classics.
[ Laughter ]
-Classics.
-I went to --
I went to film school,
and the first one we watched was
"Finding Nemo."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-No, it's really fun.
It's really, really fun.
-Yeah.
-And I mean it.
It's like we -- we watch movies,
and I've got some of my best
friends on the show and --
-Wait, what were you -- were
you drinking something there?
What was --
either a tropical punch or --
-Oh, yes, we play games.
-Okay, got ya.
-And we make snacks.
I mean, it's like
the ultimate movie night.
-That sounds really --
-The ultimate girls night.
-[ Chuckling ] That's fantastic.
I also want to congratulate you
on "Forbes'" 30 Under 30.
That is a very impressive
accomplishment, and I --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you. It's very kind.
-I was at an event once
where you won an award
for your nonprofit,
Kode With Klossy.
This is where --
This is a nonprofit you have
where you're teaching
young girls how to code.
-Yes.
-How did that come about?
-So, I have been modeling
for the last 10 years.
And along the way, I --
-It'll happen for you.
It takes a long time.
-Yeah.
-10 years, I know, but just keep
at it, and it'll happen.
-I mean, how many years
have you been at it,
you've been at a career?
-I've been at modeling?
25.
-I know. I know.
-And I have not gotten
a single job, yeah.
-You're doing all right.
-Yeah.
We'll trade.
-[ Laughs ]
-But, yeah, I wanted to learn
what code was.
It was like this crazy language,
or this secret language
that people -- people knew.
I was meeting
all these entrepreneurs,
and I wanted to understand what
they knew that I didn't know.
And code is just that --
it's a language.
And so I took a class,
and there were mainly just guys
at the school and --
-This is about
three or four years ago?
-Around three or four years ago.
-Okay.
-And it kind of opened my eyes
to not only
the power of what code is
and how you can really use it
in very creative ways
and build really anything
you want to.
And I -- I realized that
I wanted to reach out to the
girls that -- that follow me
and -- and offer them
opportunities to learn.
-And so, did you start it?
It's fantastic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow. Thank you.
-And --
-Do you know what --
Do you how to code?
-Do I know how to code?
-Do you know what code is?
-I wouldn't even know
how to start.
How do you start?
-I'll teach you.
-What's the first thing you do?
-Come to one of my camps.
So...
-You're on a computer.
-So, you're on a computer.
-Yeah.
-And it's really just that.
-Turn it on.
-You turn it on.
-Okay.
-And it's -- it's -- it's
a language, like anything else.
And you can build
whatever you want.
-And, so, some of the girls
that have gone through
your program --
Is it like a camp?
Is that how you set it up or...?
-Yes, so, we have camps
across the country.
And we've taught hundreds
of girls to learn how to code.
-And they've --
they've developed apps.
What are some apps that
girls at your coding camp...
-I mean, the girls are amazing.
These girls are 13 to 18.
They're pre-college age.
And they're really kind of
at that moment in life
where they're deciding
who they believe they are,
what they believe
they're capable of,
and deciding what they want
to do with their life.
And it's just this amazing
moment to be able to, you know,
teach these girls a skill set
that can be applied
to any direction
that they're passionate about.
-It's fantastic.
And it's definitely
a tool for the future.
So it's really impressive
you did that.
-Yes. You should
come learn with me.
-I'm gonna go to your
coding camp. I can't wait.
'Cause I think --
I got to be honest.
I think modeling
might not happen.
So...
[ Laughter ]
I just want to congratulate you
on this.
You -- You ran the marathon!
-Yes.
-This year!
-Oh, my God. That was --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Are you a --
-Have you run a marathon?
-I have.
I've run a couple, yeah.
It is -- It's no easy feat.
Were you a runner?
Was that --
-Was never a runner.
-See, that's crazy.
-Never a runner.
I have these long legs,
but that running
just was not my thing, ever.
And I decided, you know,
what is the craziest thing
that I could do?
Well, probably running
a marathon is up there.
-[ Chuckling ] Uh-huh.
-And so, it's a challenge
I always wanted to tackle.
And New York City Marathon
is amazing.
-Were you recognized?
Were people --
Did people know it was you
over the course of the marathon?
-Yeah. I mean, I wore my name,
and, you know...
-Yeah, so that helped.
-...I'm covered in sweat.
It was not
the most glamorous moment.
But it's just
this surreal experience,
running through the city,
running through the streets.
People are like, you know,
cheering you on.
You feel like you want to, like,
melt into a puddle,
and people are like,
"Don't stop! Keep going!"
-[ Laughs ] That is great.
-So, yeah.
-That is a wonderful part
about it.
And I would imagine,
even if you were trying to hide,
you were going to stand out
a little bit
just on a height level.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. I didn't run in these,
but, you know.
-Yeah, that's right.
-Yeah.
-And this is you at the finish
line, which is fantastic.
-Yes. All my girls.
-There you go.
That is wonderful.
-I made my friends run with me,
so...
-That's very nice of you.
-They got wrapped into it.
-I know -- I want to ask you
real quick --
I know you're
a bit of a sports fan.
-Yeah. Major sports fan.
-I know you're from St. Louis.
The St. Louis Rams
were a football team --
they're not anymore.
-[ Sighs ]
-They moved to Los Angeles,
and they're having
a fantastic year.
-I know.
-Can you take any joy in that?
-I can't talk about it.
You know,
I am a die-hard football fan
and supported the Rams
for years --
the good, the bad, the ugly.
And, you know,
I'm a St. Louis girl,
so there's a part of me
that's a little heartbroken
that they are no longer
a St. Louis team.
-Yeah.
-So I am a free agent looking
for a new team to support.
-Okay, gotcha.
-I've been supporting
the Giants.
-All right, that's nice.
-I've got my own fantasy team.
-I invite all
of the social media accounts
of the 32 football teams
to reach out to you
on your social media,
and I'm sure they'd be
very, very happy to have you.
-They can pick me up
on the waiver wire.
-Yeah. Congratulations
on everything, Karlie.
-Thank you.
-It's always such a pleasure
to see you.
Karlie Kloss, everybody.
-Thank you.